[Applause]
good afternoon and it's great to see all
of you here yes I'm a novice novice at
the cop that's true not so much actually
on unsustainability because in the
previous Commission in the Younger
Commission I held the responsibility for
sustainability for five years and
thinking back to be perfectly honest
with you when we started as younger
Commission sustainability was already a
big issue but not at the highest
political level because when creating
that Commission it was simply overlooked
and when the European Parliament
criticised jean-claude Juncker for this
I happen to be sitting next to him and
he looked at me he said well France
every month will be responsible for
sustainability and it's one of the
nicest things that happened to me
frankly so I want to to share with you a
couple of lessons I learned very briefly
and why it is important to take a more
holistic view of the issue first of all
we are in the middle of arguably the
biggest change the planet has ever seen
as long as humans are on it and I always
tell my kids you know I begin with this
remark we can't do without the planet
but the planet can very do without
without house it did without us for a
long long time keep that in mind
and if we don't behave on the planet the
planet that sooner or later is going to
get rid of us because we do too much
harm and it's a very direct way of
explaining to my kids what our
responsibility is and I say this because
we have a tendency to compartmentalize
the issues we talk about emissions and
that we have a climate crisis which is
linked to those emissions
and then we step out of that debate and
then we talk about biodiversity loss and
the crisis that is creating then we step
out of that debate and we look at the
livability of our cities and we see that
in Europe more than 400,000 people die
premature deaths because of bad air
quality etc etc then we look at our
economy and we say we have to protect
jobs so don't hurry up too much but we
are at a time when mother earth is
telling us I can't do this anymore in
this way where the population of the
earth is growing so we need to find a
solution for that and where we're in the
middle of an industrial revolution which
is going to upturn the entirety of the
world's economy so how do we bring these
things together first of all this change
is going to happen whether we like it or
not whether we do something about it or
not it's going to have so we have a
choice do we become masters of that
change do we organize it in such a way
so that we leave no one behind
or do we just let it happen and then see
what happens and one thing I know if we
study previous industrial revolutions
unchecked an industrial revolution will
create a small group of incredible
winners and a huge huge group of
incredible losers that's in the nature
of disruption caused by Industrial
Revolution so it needs to be managed and
corrected and that's why you have
governments and politics that's why you
have democracies but now with the
climate crisis coming in there and the
fact that Mother Earth can't sustain us
if we continue to live like we live we
need to combine the two things we need
to make sure that this climate crisis
doesn't lead to a few winners and the
huge amount of losers and that the
Industrial Revolution does do the same
thing at the same time so they need to
reinforce each other in the right
direction that is actually at the core
of the debate you are having here today
and that's why when we present the
European Green Deal tomorrow we want to
try and
show how sure how a holistic approach of
the issue is the only approach that it's
going to be effective looking at all the
issues that we will have to tackle and
all the measures we will have to take
because in many of the debates first of
all what is disappearing is the issue of
climate deniers I think that group is
getting smaller and smaller so that
shouldn't take up too much of our energy
anymore I'm still willing to engage with
him but they're getting you know even
Jeremy Clarkson has given up I think so
that's that's one thing secondly and
that's really worrying there's an
increasing group of people who on the
basis of science because science is
telling us almost on a weekly basis it's
even worse than we thought
while saying pardon my french was
screwed anyway never mind that to me is
the biggest threat to what we need to do
people think screwed anyway never mind
let's live it out as long as we can and
then we'll see so we have to combat that
but we can only combat that if we can
see demonstrate if we could show what we
can do and that which you can show that
people are a part of that and they could
do something themselves as well that
should be the context of I believe
presenting this the third problem I have
and I get this almost every day people
say yes we know there's a climate crisis
we know we need to do something about
this but steady on not too much think
about our industry etc etc and they
introduced a contradiction which is so
false and we have to be so careful about
this because it is my view that if we do
not if industry if our economy does not
embrace the necessity to go to that
paradigm shift and to organize it the
only thing you do is slow down decline
and
possibly postpone the inevitable but at
what cost because that's the fourth
element final element or is this
argument okay okay but we can't afford
it
you yourself are saying this will need
hundreds of billions of investment every
year true but can we afford to do
nothing
should we not and this is also a
challenge to the scientific community by
the way should we not tell people what
the costs are of not doing anything
apart from the moral costs knowing that
more than four hundred thousand people
in Europe die premature deaths because
of poor air quality apart from the cost
economically the more costs of not
acting when you know this is incredible
and I'm not even going into erratic
weather and floods and all of that and
all of that so the case should be made
that it's in our interest and it's
possible and it's economically viable to
take this transition as an opportunity
and do it and this you know already the
circular economy is proving a viable
option which creates new jobs but just
take cities for instance that's just at
the global confident of mayors where I
said that cities are are very
interesting because they they are the
place where the problems are
concentrated but also where the
creativity resides to find the solutions
so just imagine in cities you look at
our city's temperatures in many cities
in southern Europe a rising air quality
is getting lower urban transportation
getting more complicated construction is
also getting more complicated look at
nature based solutions we were proposed
tomorrow shall go into the details a
massive program of reforestation in
Europe because I believe it is necessary
sort of to do something in the different
direction than what Europe has been
doing for it for centuries but as
part of that I would like to see
greening of our cities greening the
cities makes them more liveable improves
the air quality brings a temperature
down creates carbon sink and all of that
that's a native nature based solution
that people can relate to at a very
personal individual basis this is
something we can do ourselves
immediately and I think it speaks to
sort of the very heart of our cortex you
know this is something we have a
relationship with it's part of a natural
environment look at what we can do in
the circuit economy with mace waste
management what if we can get cities to
come together to devise a plan to have a
mission free public transport it's not
that difficult it can be done but if
individual cities do this on an
individual basis they perhaps cannot
gather the strength to negotiate the
best possible deals with those who build
the infrastructure and those who provide
the electric buses etc but what if we
get cities to scale that on a way that
you don't order 100 or 200 buses but
5,000 6,000 10,000 you get a completely
different proposition and you make a
very interesting proposition to European
car industry that is looking for new
opportunities my intention today is not
to give you a blueprint our intention
tomorrow is also not to go to give you
blueprint it's an open invitation
because if governance governance public
and private has to change and it does
because of this new reality it also has
to be more open open to people bringing
other solutions and better ideas open to
a dialogue and whether this is the right
choice to make etcetera etcetera but at
the same time it has to be rigorous we
have to commit to be a climate mutual
continent by 2050 that is a rigorous
commitment and if you make that rigorous
commitment you have to think back what
does that mean for 2040 what does that
mean for 2030 which is you know 10 years
down the road it's tomorrow
and this is this rigger I believe will
offer the clarity to industry and
investors and banks on where we will go
and that will hopefully unleash the
level of investment that is needed to
scale up a climate action also through
economic means also based on nature
based solutions I strongly believe in
this approach but the rigor in saying
this is what the science says this is
what we need to do that's what I need to
be in ten years time that's what we want
to be in in a generations time that
rigor is not saying to the outside world
so this is the prescription and we will
just tell you exactly what to do step by
step no but it is the framework within
which the measures should be taken that
we can take I think corporate business
is ready for this I get clear signals
that the banking sector and the
financial sector is ready for this I
still think we have a lot of work to do
to convince small and medium sized
enterprises then they have a huge part
to play in this because they you know
given also the the economic challenges
they've had over the last ten years they
don't have the luxury to look ahead ten
or twenty years they're thinking about
tomorrow and next year
and we should be offering them some
solutions and I want to end on on a
second concrete point I already
mentioned the issue of reforestation and
greening city's second concrete point we
need to build differently it is possible
to build with different materials that
are sustainable it is also possible to
create building materials that are more
sustainable that's one side of things
but we have so many existing buildings
they also need to be brought up to a
level of energy efficiency that helps us
reduce emissions especially in cities to
do that houses will have to be isolated
solar panels will have to be installed
or heat pumps will have to be installed
for many people this is an investment
they'd like to make but they can make
they don't have that
ready so we should be thinking with
other partners and ways of empowering
smaller medium-sized enterprises to make
an offer to residents or to corporations
or to other owners of property and
saying we will do this work will isolate
your house make it energy sustainable
this might cost 1520 thousand euros we
will not ask you to pay for that
we'll ask you to sign a contract and
from the day we have done this you will
pay the same amount of money you're now
paying for energy but then to us and
then after a certain amount of time you
will own what is done to your house your
house will be more valuable will be
worth more than today and you energy
bill will go down because I hear this a
lot yes all very nice but you're asking
us to pay so much more for energy we
can't afford it so this is another
concrete proposal and I'd love to end on
that where you can say that you can
bring in the economy and smaller
medium-sized enterprises to do the right
thing
create more jobs these are jobs that
can't go anywhere because they have to
be done on the spot jobs for people
especially in the lower middle class in
the middle class who are most squeezed
in this economy and in this economic
transition and this is a way we can have
everybody engaged in a momentous
movement which I believe we cannot
afford to miss thank you very much
[Applause]